this has been
one of the toughest challenges I've ever
set
there are times that I honestly didn't
think both restaurants were going to
make it and I started to panic
and as the clock ticks away the
restaurants just started emerging coming
individual restaurants with identity
character the atmosphere in both
restaurants amazing the food stunning
and on the back of the last three hours
we've made it incredibly difficult for
me to decide on which restaurants go
through to the final that's what a
pop-up restaurant is all about a one-off
one-night-only unique experience
and on the back of that performance it's
such a close call based on everything
I've seen who's gonna get me understand
flavors see how can we go through this
everything I tasted the proper Spanish
dish picture is beautifully presented
plate of food everything
I've listened to casa me a restaurant
check on Table four first one to make
her happy she wants potatoes can we do
it yes if we could do them chef please
the restaurant going through to the
final
this
just a man yes
well done thank you well done you can
smoke
as it was a new challenge so it was
really tough obviously disappointed but
I mean the guys they are amazing
just me are in the final because they
understood for the first time in this
competition what customers once John
Romita dropped the frills and they
delivered
we've got two little geniuses but my god
can they cook [ __ ] impressive